[Applause]
by now we know what Donald Trump's about
but it's different with Democrats the
party's in Jordan identity crisis and
it's created a smorgasbord of twenty20
hopefuls in the leafless chill of Iowa
they need heat behind them and after 500
miles we didn't find it where you might
expect
Joe Biden is the front-runner nationally
but his crowds are small sleepy graying
and the performance is uneven I had more
energy than all of them so it comes from
the heart they like Uncle Joe's personal
touch and his refusal to take a hard
turn to the left this is what is best at
Meeting voters face to face
hearing our personal stories even asking
without contact details as well but when
it came to the speech it's why the slow
build-up there is another man in the
middle mare to eat food a judge he's a
veteran and he's openly gay but he's
also just 38 years old just how critical
are winning over independence and
Republicans to Democrats success this
election how vital well I think it is
important for us not only to defeat
Donald Trump but to do it by a big
enough margin that trumpism itself goes
into the history books for that to
happen we need to unite not just the
left not just progressives and
dyed-in-the-wool Democrats but
independents and Republicans senator
Elizabeth Warren is running often
literally on a radically different
ticket she's a progressive series about
inequality and corporate power her
events have a folksy familiarity you
talked a lot about structural change at
this time in America do you think it's
enough to win that battle on ideas alone
talking about our country is always
about the head and the heart
simultaneously the structural change I
talk about is let's ask the billionaires
the pitch in two cents so we can have
Universal child care for every baby in
this country that she's fighting for the
same votes as an independent where the
cult-like appeared
Bernie Sanders is banking on young
voters it's a gamble and he knows it if
there is a low voter turnout let me be
very frank we're gonna lose but if there
is
[Applause]
[Music]
swearing on
[Music]
like Trump rallies there's electricity
here but Democrats have learned the hard
way
the quiet voter can often gain the
loudest voice would even Sky News
[Applause]